uh he's a great athlete they're right
there watch him finish up this one
josh christopher gives asu the lead back
team leader um he does it defensively
and offensive and i like how he started
this game getting his teammates involved
and then now he's done looking for his
own how about christopher turning
defense into offense feld
and eddie's son jaylen house setting up
josh christopher to the buckets
[Music]
a team trying to live up to lofty
expectations
christopher another flush could you
couldn't afford to not have it be an
emphasis
what's what it's supposed to be i mean
you can play no nice dish right there
josh christopher
the third ally for the game for asu they
have to do to get that lead
go to patrick christopher's brother josh
christopher
lean in use the glass strong legs but
look not giving up on the play
gets above the rim but when he gets to
those elbows situation like
the position where kobe michael jordan
and paul pierce the moss ample size but
33
to start this season another turnover
opportunity
for christopher and he's got help but he
doesn't need it
all the way to the bucket and he's going
to the line yes for arizona state before
they
navigate their way back to pac-12 play
christopher to the goal mostly of
smiling on a cloudy day
but that guy aaron holliday i mean he
dominated
dominated for the bruins to be a most
valuable players
on their alumni list james harden
russell westbrook kareem
going right down to the final possession
hopefully we'll get to overtime too
great recovery gets it himself i mean
that's aki milaj one that's bill russell
that's scotty pippen through the defense
people are relocating right there again
reichel's looking in the corner he lost
vision of the
christopher the two-handed stuff look
out even
earl probably should have gone up with
that first one over his left shoulder
and all of the unrest
around the country social justice has
been a big issue in our country
empire classic two campfire classic will
take away some of the sting of
pulled down by graham here come the sun
devils
that jumper was strong but it's
contested as well
and christopher schenpe huh
hard to believe it's hard to believe
they'd let a guy named champion on to a
golf course as nice
christopher and then had additional
delays because of covert protocols which
you have to follow
please wear a mask totally distant throw
it down josh
so glad to see john anderson the
longtime trainer for the sun devils
out there with marcus bagley the younger
brother of marvel
poloco went straight up so no foul and
christopher still banks it in showing
some strength there dies and strength
and power
as an advantage but that's not the basis
of your game the locos got a real future
cabela's turns it over here is bagley
check that christopher again showing off
his skill
here's christopher for three times
he's got 10 points now in the game so
hopefully you're not confused
all it does is mean that bagley has one
personal foul along with the technical
not too personal
that's his third triple
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here
and one
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]